julio jones falcons we know he's
available now the falcons made sure
multiple reporters knew monday morning
there it is hey julio jones is available
not now june 2 but we can work out a
deal now jay glazer reported that the
ravens asked the falcons about julio
jones but his contract is a problem now
look it's not like the ravens didn't
know about the contract it's not the
contract's the problem the problem is
the falcons don't want to pay yeah
that's right million 15.3 that's fully
guaranteed or julio doesn't want to
restructure in a way that that is not
advantageous to him or maybe he just
doesn't want to play for the ravens and
he's not willing to restructure he he
has no reason to take a penny less than
15.3 million because it's fully
guaranteed
just like teddy bridgewater wasn't going
to take a penny less than 10 million as
part of this deal that sent him to
denver because he's got 10 million fully
guaranteed so it's 15-3 julio's making
it i really think it comes down to when
you consider caroline is paying seven of
10 million guaranteed to teddy
bridgewater right dolphins paying six of
nine million that was guaranteed to eric
flowers
i think the problem is ravens said hey
you want a second round pick for this
guy you gotta you gotta pay five six
seven million dollars of his salary
definitely a hundred percent i'm with
you i think that's exactly the logic i
mean it's just it's too risky just to go
wait we'll take julio jones at this
point of his career for north of 15
million dollars a year
and you know they know what the rest of
us know in football i mean julio jones
can barely practice it's always just
like we're gonna make a decision on
friday or saturday or the day of the
game and see what he is
you know so no one's going to pay 15
million a year for a guy that's his age
that has that injury history that they
know is you know
has to have a miracle every week to kind
of get on the field on a sunday the
talent when he is on the field and
everything it's it's damn good there's
no doubt about it but i don't think
teams are going to be able to swallow
the pill of that money unless it gets to
around the 10 million 8 8 9 million
something like that mark to make them
feel comfortable uh because of that
little injury history he's got
and there's a loose correlation between
money and draft capital and
the more that the falcons will want the
ravens or any other team to pay
of that 15.3 million the less that team
is exactly give up right in draft cap
right it's it's it go it goes back and
forth the more you want and draft
capital the more you better pay of that
15.3 million and look just because
it didn't work with the ravens
that doesn't mean it can't swing back
around with the ravens they got time
yeah and teams will continue to be
interested the reason they put the word
out before the draft is you you don't
want a team that would have potentially
traded for julio jones drafting right a
receiver and then closing the door on
what would be a need for julio jones uh
in hindsight it's obvious it's not a
coincidence that three different
reporters have the same idea
the same notion the same door is open
for julio jones on the same damn day
three days before the draft starts this
is the falcons
pulling the court on the lawnmower to
get everyone aware that he's in play and
and so far we know about the ravens
presumably others have called too
because that's what teams do this time
of year they make phone calls they
hopefully they have unlimited plans on
their cell phones because they're
calling and calling and calling and
calling to see all the possibilities
before they make decisions otherwise
you haven't done your homework you
haven't done your due diligence and when
the boss asks you a tough question well
did you look into this did you look into
that you can say yes i did yes i did yes
i did yes i did
did you say minutes on the cell phone
like that was still a thing like that is
is it i don't know i've had unlimited
years is that the kind of thing i don't
think it's no longer a thing yeah i can
remember get the music ready to call
back
remember
when you picked up the phone and dialed
a long distance number
it was like you had rented premium space
on a rocket to mars that's the price of
that call and you better finish your
business and get the hell off the phone
otherwise that phone bill is going to be
more than the mortgage payment that's
what it used to be now you can you pick
up the phone and call china and it
doesn't cost you any more than what you
pay per month it's amazing it is amazing
it is
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports